[Musique]
ce dont nous sommes certains, c'est
qu'Internet se développe, c'est une plus grande partie
de la vie des gens heureusement et les gens
veulent du divertissement, ils veulent pouvoir
s'échapper et se connecter les temps sont
difficiles ou joyeux
[Musique]
J'ai certainement parlé à
beaucoup de clients qui leur parlent tous les jours
et beaucoup d'entre vous essaient de
calmer les angoisses, des trucs de stress comme
ça
aider à dormir la nuit et puis aussi
les gens ont normalement trop de choses à faire  faites
donc vous savez que c'est un vous savez d'un
point de vue récréatif peut en quelque sorte
rendre la journée plus rapide et un peu plus
intéressante
[Musique]
la semaine dernière a été folle, nous avons
augmenté la même chose d'environ 100% dans
tous les pays scandinaves donc  Je pense que
c'est parce que maintenant nous sommes habitués
à la nouvelle normalité et maintenant nous devons nous
amuser un peu plus en fait, vous savez,
vous savez dans nos vies
[Music] a
certainement vu beaucoup de
gens vouloir des vélos qui veulent en quelque sorte
aime se déplacer dans la ville en voulant
un vélo solide juste pour
leur donner une certaine mobilité en termes de travail
mais aussi en termes de sortie d'
une maison s'ils sont sur le point de s'arrêter
[Musique]
maintenant mr.  Jana vous les gars
vous